every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bear that
you'll be fine without everybody it's
Joshua fields mill burger and this is
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're gonna have a bit
of a conversation we're recording this
six days after the United States
presidential election so this is the
Monday after the Tuesday which is the
first Tuesday after the first Monday of
November 2016 thank you for clarifying
that I I don't really know what today's
day but he is six days after the
presidential election we were gonna
record this last week but I got a little
sick and I got more sick throughout the
week and then my voice was just gone I
didn't want to come in and just call on
the mic for thirty minutes and so Ryan
and I are just gonna have a conversation
today I've got a few notes but not much
and I was gonna write something about
this election because so many people are
surprised so many people are distraught
so many people are excited elated happy
joyful so many people are afraid or
terrified they're they're living in fear
I think that we're at a point now where
there are people who are maybe even both
at the same time we recited and and
afraid and so most of you know that this
show is rather a political it's an
atypical show but it's also a political
show meaning we don't get on here and
espouse our personal political we don't
talk politics we don't usually talk
religion right there there are topics
that we typically avoid but but today
we're gonna we're gonna dive into it
yeah and although I think that this will
still be a relatively apolitical show I
don't write I never asked you who you
voted for and I'm not gonna ask you here
on the air obviously but I think it'd be
safe to say I wouldn't be surprised if
you and I voted for four different
people probably I know that in the
primaries we certainly
supportive different people and many of
our friends are we that we have are
going to be anywhere on the political
spectrum from Republican and
conservative to Democrat and socialist
and libertarian and Green Party I've
talked to quite a few friends over the
the past week and and people from all
over the spectrum and had conversations
trying to better understand and I think
really the the the place where I am I
was shocked that Donald Trump became
President of the United States he's
president-elect right now and I was
truly shocked when that happened I I
never thought that could happen good bad
or indifferent I just it didn't I didn't
expect it to happen right
well yeah I mean he doesn't you know
there's the political experience isn't
there you know he's been known to be a
reality TV star so you know just like a
lot of people years ago I mean he tried
to run I think in 2000 I think 12 second
yeah talk about in 88 1988 Wow so it's
but but he's such a controversial figure
that you didn't anticipate some and he's
had so many of these gaffes that had any
other politician had these gaffes it
would have automatically sort of
disqualified them like I can think back
to politicians like John Kerry who was a
pretty typical politician right a career
politician but when he said I voted for
the war before I voted against it or
maybe race versa
like that was it and in fact if you were
to step back and talk about that you
could explain what he was talking about
well I voted for this thing until until
the thing changed until I got more
information as well and then of course I
changed my mind I voted against it but
it made him feel like the squishy sort
of politician even though you in a sound
byte it made him sound like a squishy
politician but but by and large it was
an explainable comment if you were to
step back and do a deeper dive well
there were many gaffes throughout this
this campaign for sure and we're not
going to get into the to the the
nitty-gritty or the the politics up yeah
before
before we even get deeper in this
conversation I just want to say for the
listeners like first off if I was
listening to this I would probably like
not listen to a political debate between
two of my are not debate but a political
conversation just because I'm so tired
of it
but I just want to let people know that
you know this is not a this is not going
to be a bashing session this is not like
my whole goal of this conversation
between you and I is for me to hold back
any negative comments when it comes to
anything or anyone I mean I think it's
just this is gonna be more of a
conversation about kind of a pulse on
where we feel like the country is at and
in kind of a discussion more than a than
a debate or you know tearing people down
or anything
totally agree in fact I think that a big
chunk of this election was pretty much
just a repudiation of a lot of that that
sentiment that's going on in the country
right now the tearing down from both
sides you know you are this and you were
this and I'm going to blame this person
or blame this person or blame blame
blame and I want to do the opposite of
that because I think it is easy at first
our first instinct maybe as human beings
or maybe just as our culture is to step
back and blame and on the surface there
are a lot of people you could blame for
this outcome sure whether you're a trump
supporter or a Hillary supporter or a
third party support whether you know
yeah you're non-voter you can blame a
lot of people and so I sort of made a
list like at first I saw it I saw
election night instantly people started
blaming the people who voted for third
parties so like Jill Stein or Gary
Johnson supporters and and they were
really upset that that other people
voted for for someone else as opposed to
voting for their candidate well first
off I understand the sentiment but I
think I think that sentiment by itself
is mistaken and the reason I think that
is well the numbers just don't bear out
if if everyone who voted for a third
party person which by the way is your
right as an American and you know I
think most of us would agree that the
two-party system hasn't worked very well
and that's why we actually got a Donald
Trump who is very much a sort of third
party candidate doesn't conform to the
ideals of either party but what I found
is that people who are blaming these
these third party
these other entities whether it's its
Jill Stein Garry Johnson Evan McMullen
etc people who voted for them most of
them the the exit poll was show Ryan
that that 55% of them would have just
stayed home if they wouldn't have voted
for a third party and then it was pretty
split down the middle it moved a little
bit toward Hillary and in this race but
but in all honesty if you were taken all
the aggregate of all the third party
people he would have split between
Hillary and Trump and neither person you
wouldn't had a different outcome as my
point right and so in fact what I would
would encourage people is that if you
were strongly supporting a third party a
third party person but you but you said
well you know I the reason I don't vote
for a third party is because they could
never win well why can't they ever win
well because no one ever votes for a
third party it's this weird circular
logic
we'll never end up getting a another
person outside of this two-party fold
this two-party recipe if we don't if we
don't start looking at these other
parties and taking them more seriously
so if you're discontented by by the
third parties maybe instead of placing
the blame on them let's place the the
the blame on the bigger system well
that's also a problem right so so we
have we have people who are now blaming
the Democrats right well you should have
brought in Bernie Sanders or or Joe
Biden or or Martin O'Malley or whomever
right and and I mean I understand why
you'd want to blame that as well yeah
that there is a there's there's
certainly some logic to say in hindsight
well Democrats didn't run the perfect
candidate and that's why she lost right
well it's true I mean but there are also
there are no such thing as perfect
candidates or some candidates who are
better than others and in this election
quite often we heard people say it's the
it's the lesser of two evils and you're
voting for the lesser of two evils the
problem with that is what well some
people thought Donald Trump was the
lesser of two evils and some people
thought that Hillary Clinton was the
lesser of two evils and there are
certainly compiled arguments from both
sides and I was talking to a friend of
ours and I
Sam I wouldn't name his name but this
weekend we had a an hour-long
conversation and I think you and I Ryan
we are we're gonna struggle with the the
same thing here throughout this
conversation is he's a pastor in the
south and so you know who I'm talking
about probably school with with this
person yes and he doesn't share the same
beliefs as I do for sure but I think we
have similar values and he didn't he he
personally didn't vote for Donald Trump
but he knows that most of his
congregation did vote for Donald Trump
yeah and he also knows that he can't get
out there and and so so he had a sort of
staff meeting the the day after the
election and he goes he just want to
take everyone's temperature
hey how's everyone doing here today
because he knows he didn't vote for him
and so he was sort of projecting his own
feelings and saying you know what I I
think what he was saying is you know
what like we're gonna get through this
together but then he realized like oh
everyone here is like really excited
yeah about this outcome he's like wait a
minute
I realize I can't go out and and share
my political beliefs in front of the
congregation because some of them won't
be able to then take my message of what
I'm trying to teach or preach to them
then won't take it seriously and the
same thing for the people who support
Hillary Clinton that if he were to come
out and say that he is really excited
yeah yeah he's or if you would have said
I voted for Donald Trump the people who
supported Hillary Clinton would have
been like well now I can't take your
messages seriously either
and so that's why I think Ryan and I are
walking on on a bit of a tightrope here
is our message is a political living a
meaningful life with less when we go out
on the road we certainly have Trump
supporters we have Hillary supporters we
have Republicans Democrats we have
people who don't vote we have high
school kids who can't vote we have have
people who have never voted in their
lives and they're living in their 80s or
90s who come out to our events in fact
in our documentary we have two people
who were vocal opponents on both sides
we have people like sam harris who was a
very vocal supporter of
of Hillary Clinton and and he did a
great job he did a podcast episode
called the lesser of two evils
and he spent the first half hour tearing
down Hillary Clinton hmm
just to give you the case of why he's
voting for her and then our friend
Joshua Becker who has done I think four
different Facebook live sessions talking
about his support for Donald Trump and
he is one of the people who inspired us
to become minimalist and he lives with
his minimalist family and he's a big
supporter of Donald Trump Joshua Becker
the author of clutter free with kids and
and and he did decide to take a
political stance this time around and so
I think what we want to do is we want to
provide perspective from from both sides
and and so we can go down this list of
well who should I blame you know I've
heard I've heard these these politicians
now Ryan that they've come out are not
politicians but pundits I should say
have come out and say well especially
people from the left we need to blame
white people for this election right
because the white people they just voted
for this in their words they voted for
this racist misogynistic guy who who is
a repudiation of the progress we've made
over the last eight years or whatever
and and that sounds true at the surface
but then you realize that wait a minute
Donald Trump got only 1% more of the
white vote then Mitt Romney did and no
one was going out and calling Mitt
Romney this this racist misogynist
whatever he was a pretty vanilla
politician four years ago and a pretty
standard Reaganesque sort of centrist
Republican and and so you had you had
this guy who got only 1% more of the
white vote so it wasn't like you had
this huge white turnout so then who do
you blame do you blame white women
because the strange thing about that is
white women voted more for Donald Trump
mm-hmm
then for Hillary Clinton which blows me
away I was totally shocked to hear that
statistic from the exit polls
well but of course more more minorities
certainly turned out black people
Hispanics especially women of color
turned out for Hillary Clinton but then
you also hear that Donald Trump got more
black women that voted for him right
then Mitt Romney did he has 7% of black
women to vote for him are those people
are those women black women racists
misogynists no I don't think so I think
the problem we're running into right now
and the reason that we have difficulty
having discussions around this is you
know what we we put people in this
monolith and say we blame the white
people we blame Hispanics we blame blame
blame blame blame these monoliths not
all white people the same not all
Hispanic people are saying by the way
Hispanics almost 1/3 of Hispanics voted
for Donald Trump
no one saw that coming unbelievable it's
crazy and so we're at this place where
most of the polls were wrong most of the
pundits were wrong and and most of us
are in shock whether we the people who
supported Donald Trump they're in shock
that their guy actually won I mean I I
was watching the night of the acceptance
speech the Donald Trump game I saw Mike
Pence his vice president he was standing
there in the corner he looked like he
was in shock like oh my god I can't
believe this actually happened and so
you can go back to the weeks before the
election and everyone thought that
Hillary Clinton had it in the bag and it
was similar to this whole brexit thing
that happened with with Great Britain
everyone was in shock of that as well
and so who do we blame I think Brian I
think we blame both both nobody and
everybody and here's what I mean by that
there's no single person or group who's
to blame because if you want to blame a
a person who voted for gary johnson well
let's say you shifted his vote to
Hillary or Trump let's be honest a
single vote doesn't matter in this
election it didn't matter
one vote didn't change anything so if we
blame everyone it's just the masses and
the culmination of everything that
happened we're all part of that and once
we realized
all part of that I think we can work
together to be to be more accepting and
Ryan you and I know a lot of people who
are in despair right now who feel the
sense of fear and and I have a few
talking points here that of I took some
screenshots from social media
and and from different places on the web
over the last week and some of our
friends who are genuinely in fear and so
Ryan I want to read this to you this is
this is out there on it's public our
friend bill who lives in Kentucky we
used to work with back in the corporate
world and he made this comment the day
after the election he said you know I'm
pretty excited he's saying was in jest
obviously I'm pretty excited for my
disabled daughter to grow up in a
society where it's acceptable for her to
be both mocked and groped hmm
and I feel his pain and III want to say
that I can't imagine that the 60 million
people who who voted for Donald Trump
and maybe it's my me being overly
optimistic as I tend to be maybe the I
can't think that that those the 60
million people want a world where it's
acceptable for Bill's disabled daughter
to be mocked for being to say aborting
to be groped as a female I don't think
that that was the sentiment of most of
those people no I think you know I would
consider myself one of those people
who's in despair right now but you know
it's not it's not because of you know
what's to come it's not because you know
this must you know this person who has
been led to believe by the media to be
you know misogynist you know I don't
know the guy personally but yeah
certainly there are videos and plenty he
made some misogynistic yeah yeah no
questions about I'm just trying my
hardest not to like just you know sit
here and like call out all the bad
things that that we've all seen about
Donald Trump um but you know I'm more in
despair because of the pulse on the
nation man the fact that you have you
know 60 million people who voted for
someone that extreme
who is known to disrespect women who is
known to mock disabled people because it
what it tells me is that a like either
sixty million people
I'm not every single one of them but
either millions of people don't know
about all this and they're not paying
attention or they're looking past it
because that is how angry they are or
they support it there are there's a
small fraction I mean sure I would say
I'm gonna be optimistic yeah you and say
it's a very small portion of the people
who actually support that type of
behavior but you know I'm in despair
right now because our country is it is
divided like very much so between this
Democrat and you know Republican parties
I mean it's unbelievable to me that
there are like people you know thousands
and thousands people on the street like
protesting it's like it makes no sense
to me because we have a democracy we
have rules around it this is what's
happened there you know we can sit here
and be against it but at the end of the
day either you support the laws or you
don't and the fact that there's
thousands of people who are in the
streets and and they're they're not
being violent I mean for all intents and
purposes like they're very they are
peaceful protests there are some
violence that has occurred during this
protest but for the for the large
proportion of them they have been pretty
peaceful but the fact that our country
is is in despair makes me in despair if
that makes any sense it does and and I
think there a lot of people who are are
afraid right now and you know it's it's
easy for the two of us even though we
have different political beliefs it's
easy for the two of us to as white males
to to be in to not have the same amount
of fear as a person of color or as a
woman you know I was talking to my
partner Beck's and and obviously you
don't we have a three-year-old daughter
and and it's gonna be different for for
people who are are not white males and
we it doesn't mean that you know I I'm
in a position where I'm feeling guilty
for being a white male but you know it
what it is and here's what I will say is
that if you are in fear if you are if
you do feel despair we have to you the
people who don't have that same fear
whether you voted for left or right or
anywhere else you need to be there to
support those people who are afraid
right now right and especially if you
voted for Donald Trump and and you know
someone who is is a Muslim or you know
someone who is a person of color who now
thinks there or if you know an immigrant
who thinks they're gonna get deported
yeah anyone who feels like a target yes
yeah that that's a great way to put it
if you know someone who feels like a
target we who don't feel like targets we
need to be willing to to step up and we
need to be willing to support those
people and let let them know you know
what I've got your back I know you were
afraid right now and so so really that
that's what I want the message from this
to be is not a message of blame but this
conversation needs to be a you know what
no matter where we are right now if
you're afraid know that we've got your
back yeah and blaming doesn't get us
anywhere man it's like all the things
that you listed that people are blaming
none of it it doesn't it doesn't matter
whose fault it is like the situation is
what it is and we can't go back I mean
we could sit here you know we could
blame the electoral college and in that
law do I agree with the electorate
electoral college law like there are
some circumstances that I've seen where
yeah I agree with it and then there are
other circumstances where I see I don't
agree with it but the fact is is that
that is the the law that we have right
now if it's something we want to change
and we have to look forward yes we can't
look back and be like oh well it's you
know it's just it's this you know
group's fault or it's this laws fault
and we're gonna go out and protest and
try and change it we can't I mean we can
go out and protest but the chances of us
changing the outcome is very very slim
the only thing we can do is look forward
and I and I think that's you know
another thing about this conversation I
really wanted to get through to our
listeners is that we have to move
forward we cannot stay here and wallow
in this in shock I'll be honest with you
though man
I mean I was before the whole whole time
leading up to the election like how many
times did I go to you and
like dude I think Trump's gonna get
elected and you were like oh no you know
the polls and and I was looking at the
polls to pretty regularly and they were
kind of back and forth but you know I
wish the the point I was shocked it
wasn't when Trump got elected I was
shocked when my grandparents a year and
a half ago said that they were gonna
vote for Trump and that both sets of
grandparents said they were gonna vote
for Trump in the primary and like that
to me like that was the sign of oh my
god like things are really getting out
of control and it's not because like my
grandparents you know are the end-all
be-all like who they vote for that suit
as president but what I've noticed
growing up is that out of every single
presidential election that I've been
alive for there was one presidential
election the when bush senior ran
against Clinton that for the for
election yeah that they voted for Bush
Senior and he didn't win but every other
single election like it's been they've
been right on the money with it so it's
it's not that like I look at them again
like the end OBO but I do look at my
grandparents like they have good heads
on their shoulders
they're middle class like they're
they're a pretty pretty good or a pretty
good example of like you're you know
standard Americans and the fact that you
know people who I respect and like I
know we're level-headed started talking
about voting for Trump like that is when
like I started to feel shocked so it's
kind of crazy to me to that like we're
all in disbelief like Trump gotta like
it we should have all been in disbelief
when he got elected for the primaries
like that's that's that was kind of the
beginning of it all yeah and I was in
disbelief to be honest with you but I
also realized that that that was a weird
circumstance and it didn't it you know
there were 17 people running and and it
it just seemed odd though the whole
thing seemed odd and it didn't seem like
it was it it was impossible and this one
seemed impossible but I tell you the
reason it seemed impossible to me is I
can tell you this is I've put myself in
a bubble the last five or six years yeah
and I've surrounded my and I in fact I
encouraged pee
let me be clear I encourage you to put
yourself in a bubble but I mean let me
expand on me alright alright guys that's
it for the show thanks for listening I
encourage you to put yourself in a
bubble I've put myself in a bubble of
people who share similar values to me we
don't always have the same belief so we
have different paths to get to those
values so Ryan and I have different
beliefs about certain things but we have
the same values my friend the pastor
friend I was talking to this weekend
have radically different beliefs but we
we are we're at a place where we get we
get to this we eventually through a very
security's route get to the same values
at least most of the time I think and I
think it's the same with all the people
in my my first here my primary
relationships and also I think my
secondary relationships we all have the
same values and then there's that that
periphery the tertiary relationships and
those people will vary and you know that
they're in and out of my life
accordingly but I tell you I've put
myself in the bubble with the primary
relationships and and with those
secondary relationships but what I
haven't done a good job of and this is
my fault is was expanding that bubble a
little bit to welcome in more points of
view in different beliefs and in having
the people who may have radically
different political beliefs from me and
and so I called up a bunch of friends
this this weekend and once I stopped
coughing every five seconds and and you
know I find it interesting because a lot
of the people I grew up with so I grew
up in a predominantly black neighborhood
and I say predominantly because if you
were to take me out we would just been
an all-black neighborhood
I was the token white kid although if
you go four or five blocks down it was a
relatively white town suburbia yeah and
and so but the neighborhood I grew up in
was was a place that was pretty much all
black and and and the the points of view
of many of my friends when I talked to
them this this weekend was not that
surprised honestly hmm they're like come
on Josh you know you know what this
country's
and they're feeling oppressed they're
not feeling scared but they're feeling
like yeah like you know what like you
should have expected a cyclone you don't
you know what what country this is a
country that's built on slavery now I
understand that is that can be a
pessimistic view and and looking
backwards but it's also their worldview
and their reality much of the time and I
was talking to my pastor friend our our
pastor friend about it this weekend
right and that hurts so bad well I was
talking to him about that and and
because he grew up in the town although
on the other side of town and he was
trying to communicate with his parent so
so my brother is black and and he was
like even even Josh and Jerome have had
two different lives after yeah after
high school right even though we we grew
up in the same place we haven't
necessarily had the same opportunities
and part of that part of that has to do
with the color of our skin yeah well no
I mean even in high school man like you
know when Jerome would be driving around
he got pulled over all the time in yeah
all the time he's been tased and it's
tased twice in his life now have I ever
even been in a situation where I've been
close to getting tased no course not
and and and so we are we are in a
country where that does happen does that
mean that most cops are our racists or
most cops have it out for bar smile no
it doesn't mean that it just means the
propensity for it to happen to you if
you're black is much higher and that's
where the whole black lives matter
movement comes from it isn't they're not
saying that all lives don't matter there
but what they're saying is that no not
all lives matter if black lives don't
matter as well and and so you have a lot
of black people who are either
distraught and then you have a lot of
women especially who I've talked to my
friend Annie back in Dayton who are just
in this affray a period the this period
of fear and there
and so I think we need to reach out to
these people and and and who we have not
extended our bubble to now again I I'm
I'm blaming myself here if I'm blaming
anyone for not extending my bubble to
two people as opposed to trying to get
into their bubble yeah let's open up our
bubble our values of living a meaningful
life to anyone who who is afraid to
anyone who has this this despair in
their lives right now now is the time
for us to reach out that's crazy I
thought I thought I had a good bubble
going on well I look like I do
you you have you ever get better one
than I look as my well my family I don't
I think I'm the only I would be willing
to say I'm the only one of my family on
both sides out of like 20 family members
I can think of I'm probably the only one
that didn't vote for Trump and with that
even like that and that's what made me
nervous about yeah being elected cuz
around I don't know myoh in Newark like
they're all in big states but even then
I still was like okay you know I'm
talking to Josh Josh's reinsuring me the
Hillary's gonna get elected everyone
that I you know all my close friends all
you know there's 20 family members but I
got you know 50/50 friends around me or
you know Facebook friends that I'll see
their feet or whatever or people I'll
run into that you know they you know
they're not gonna vote for Trump so yeah
okay okay probably Trump's not gonna get
it
but it's just amazing amazing how I have
I feel like I have extended my bubble
and still I live in a bubble if that
makes any sense well I think but I think
your approach is much better than mine I
don't know I don't have a person in my
my first tier or second tier
relationships I don't have a single
person in that bubble who voted for
Trump yeah I don't I don't have a single
person my friends family if I do it's
very few but yeah but your your family
yeah and your your whole family and I
don't have the same sort of extended
family I mean I don't yeah I don't have
a ton of mean I can't I talk to all of
them you know a few times a year but I
don't
and they might be under your tertiary
but you still love them care about them
but it doesn't mean you've been -
actually no I take that back I
definitely yeah I did my primary I
definitely do have yes some people some
friends that I have yeah who do I know
voted for Trump okay well well in but we
we intentionally put ourselves in these
bulbs and again I think it's okay but I
think we need to continue to be
intentional about about that bubble and
you know about expanding it I mean for
God's sake we moved to an island in
Montana right at liberal island yeah I
mean cuz you look at the red where it's
a red state there are two little blue
dots Bozeman and and and Missoula and
and so and it's a I mean this place is
emphatically white and if you get
outside of Missoula its aggressively
white yeah and and that was we've been
here for four years and it was really
shocking to me and it's one of the
reasons that and I've never talked about
this publicly but it's one of the
reasons I want to leave them is Ulla
personally is there are some diversity
and opinions here for sure but it is it
is not diverse and certainly not what
I'm used to you know I moved here from
Dayton Ohio which is 45 percent
african-american to Missoula Montana
which is a hundred and five percent
white wait am i sore sometimes some
people are extra white here no I mean
although III tell you that some of the
most meaningful conversations I have
here or when I go to go to song I like
four or five times a week and I'm the
only white person that goes to the sauna
where I go to pretty much it's all
American Indians
who
who are either from the reservation up
in browning and they've moved down here
for jobs and so forth or for school and
and some of the best conversations I
have maybe the conversation to have or
about race and they're different from
the conversations I had growing up in
Ohio who their their conversations about
they're even it's a different kind of
oppression that these people have have
felt and I realized that quite often we
don't when we put ourselves in these
bubbles we don't get to talk about the
the feelings that that other people feel
and the feelings aren't always rational
that we feel right that's why they're
feelings emotions have very little to do
with rationality we feel what we feel
despite what we think and and me being a
very rational person it's often easy for
me my first inclination is to dismiss
what someone feels because well that's
not the most rational approach but the
truth is that doesn't matter right you
can you can win the argument but still
lose the argument because you didn't
change how someone feels and I think
that's quite often where we go wrong and
that's where our friend sam harris he
had a great conversation after after the
election and clearly he was a Hillary
supporter and he did a great job of
articulating all the rationale behind a
Hillary presidency but it wouldn't sway
anyone's emotions I didn't feel like
yeah and that's that's what won this
election for many people were people
felt alienated and and so they wanted to
vote for something different but
different isn't always better
different can be much worse different
can be much better different is just
different it's not inherently better or
worse and and so I think we need to
continue to expand adjust expendable
yeah contract our bubbles sometimes
to ink so that we can expand somewhere
else you know I was watching this in or
was an interview it was like Michael
Moore on a panel on MSNBC and it was
like a 45-minute long segment and he
just he's did an amazing job of like
helping me understand how I need to
expand my bubble more I mean he started
talking about how you know he's like you
go to Flint Michigan and they can't
drink their water no one knows that I
mean there was some national attention
on that and then a President Obama went
out drink some water and left but
nothing has changed right since all that
and he was talking about you know like
the the American just working-class that
that a lot of us are disconnected from
and you know it's it's like you know you
and I who have we've kind of started
this atypical work and you know we're
able to support ourselves you know we
don't have the 9 to 5 but pervades
Americans out there who have the
nine-to-five and they want they want
something different and III just can't
stress enough to anyone out there who
you know feels like they don't have a
good grasp on that on that type of not
that type I don't know what the word I'm
looking for is but people in that world
if you don't have any association with
people like that like go out and find
people to talk to who you would normally
not talk to to understand like where
where their pain is what you know what
their suffering is and why they would
they want change so bad that they're
willing to ignore all of the misogyny
racist things that have come up with
Trump they won't change so bad they're
willing to look past all of that just to
have something difficult I think you and
I are in a fortunate position because we
do get to interact with tens of
thousands not hundreds of thousands of
people when we go on the road and they
literally are from all walks of life
right and yeah it's I mean we we have
every ethnicity black white Hispanic
American Indian Indian American
I mean we have people from from multiple
countries who will come out poor rich
CEOs and factory workers at the same
event and we're all asking how do I live
a more meaningful life yeah and we need
no matter who they're voting for
right right in fact I think that tends
to be why they vote for who they over
they think this is going to help me lead
a more meaningful life and I think what
we also need to do is realize that no
matter who you vote for whoever is in
office the the person who will make the
most difference in your life
is you whether there's a President Obama
a President Bush a President Clinton or
a president Trump the person who will
make the largest difference in your life
is you and that's through the optimistic
pursuit of creating the person you want
to become who's that person that is on
the horizon for you and that is the
person you should aspire to be I am I am
hopeful here Ryan we there's a pot one
of my favorite podcasts I listen to is
the brilliant idiots which you're
familiar with it's white guy and a black
guy Andrew Schultz and Charlemagne and
Charlemagne is this this hip-hop critic
radio guy radio host your hosts a the
largest morning show in the country now
it's called The Breakfast Club and he
has a book coming out next August which
I've already pre-ordered its called
black privilege hmm opportunity comes to
those who created and while I certainly
am NOT going to say there isn't a such
thing as white privilege there is but
his his argument is that you know what
there's also other privilege there's
black privilege there's female privilege
and he said I couldn't get to where I am
right now if I wasn't black I couldn't
give you the same the same perspective I
wouldn't have grown up in Moncks Corner
South Carolina on a dirt road and sold
crack as a teenager and I couldn't have
gotten to where I am now without those
experiences and he does a much better
job articulated that than I would
but what I realize is that yes we're not
all born equal Ryan you and I grew up
really
or you grew up in trailer parks I grew
up on on on WIC and food stamps
government assistance and I think my
trailers were nicer than the places you
lived in well I I mean when I was when I
was living on Warren Street manlady
grooving like shacks man yeah the house
that I grew up in is boarded up now yeah
and and you know the in the neighborhood
I grew up in most of the houses that
it's funny I've gone back there a few I
would never want to move back there and
not because of the black white white
neighborhood whatever it's a mostly
Hispanic neighborhood now but most of
the houses in the neighborhood actually
burned down there was a slumlord there
Scott I won't mention his last name but
he owned several blocks of houses there
and mysteriously over a 2 or 3 year
period the majority of them burned down
hmm
and he made a lot of money off of
insurance claim Wow
and in fact he got investigated for it
later so and and what I'll tell you is
that it was it was a terrible
neighborhood I would not want to go back
to living that way but I also want to
continue to understand people who are
are living that way yeah because yeah
fro so you and I left that that world
and sort of climbed the corporate ladder
and slowly transitioned into this other
world of not wealth necessarily but we
were we were either upper middle class
or rich in you know making close to a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
in the corporate world but you know when
I walked away from that at age thirty
there have been years where I have been
close to the poverty line I mean there's
a year we've made $23,000 and a year and
and so what I can tell you is that that
year I made $23,000 I was happier more
fulfilled and had a better sense of the
person I was and it was living a more
meaningful life a more Purpose Driven
Life a more intentional life at $23,000
a year than when I was making nearly ten
times that in the corporate world
because I had identified what my values
are and so I think we need to look
toward our values and we go back Ryan
and I wrote a whole book about this
minimalism live a meaningful life it's
our first book and
you hear us talk about our values all
the time health and relationships and
and contribution giving and growth and
creativity but but really within those
values they're all these sort of sub
values or when you talk about
relationship so what does that mean it
means it means caring and loving and
giving if it also understanding and and
accepting and and appreciating other
people right respecting other people's
beliefs even though they may be
different from yours and so we really
get into our values and one of those
values is people or relationships we
need to identify and we start asking
ourselves some difficult questions who's
the person I want to become and how do I
get there how do i strengthen my
relationships and so if anything out of
this whole whole election that has
created this dichotomy I don't want to
have the sentiment of well here are the
bad guys in here are the good guys
there's this tweet that I I saw that a
friend of ours retweeted let me see if I
can find it for you Ryan
yeah I mean just hearing that statement
right off the bat good guys versus bad
guys I mean that is that is not the
attitude I'm going to adopt it's moving
forward and that that's good it here
this this woman she and I understand
she's scared and I totally understand
the sentiment I fish think this point of
view is a mistaken point of view her
name's Kim she said if you voted for
Trump unfollow me
block me either please I don't want you
in my life mm-hmm and and so I think
that that that is closing off the bubble
and shrinking the bubble as opposed to
trying to understand people and what
I'll even go a step farther is let's try
to understand the people the people who
are actually racists and the people who
are bigots or misogynists we don't need
to accept their beliefs and they don't
have the same values as us but let's do
a better job of understanding what Spurs
that what's the spark there that makes
someone racists or misogynistic so that
we can make sure we we don't include
that in our recipe
for our own values our own beliefs our
own interests and desires and discourse
how do we how do we move forward but by
understanding those people better as
well maybe not even tolerating those
people in fact not tolerating those
people certainly not respecting racist
opinions not respecting misogynistic
viewpoints but doing a better job to
understand where they're coming from so
that we don't make the same mistakes
that other people make yeah yeah this is
a it's a crazy time man I mean for me
you know if if I had Blake some final
thoughts I would say I'm in support of
the democracy we have in place yeah yeah
well I mean technically it's a
constitutional republic so so we don't
all vote for everything and that's the
so the Electoral College argument or
whatever now there are some places where
you can't you you do get to vote for you
know California is a good example I
think they're the the booklet about the
there election there was 248 pages long
because people get to vote for pretty
much everything it's essentially a
democracy on a statewide level right but
I guess what I'm saying is is is the the
system we have in place whether you want
whether I want to be or not I'm signed
up for it for those laws and the only
thing I can do moving forward is you
know hope that Trump does a really
really good job and blows everyone away
I mean how many times have you and I
said that there should be a you know
presidential candidate that runs on a
bunch of you know crazy right-wing stuff
gets elected and then goes into the
White House and says hey you know what
not really gonna do all that stuff sorry
I kind of lied during my campaign yeah
and like he was really gonna actually
make some change so you know hopefully
that's what happens but I will say I
think there is change coming for better
or for worse and I will you know I'm not
going to root for the captain of the
ship to fail because I certainly don't
want to certainly don't want the ship to
crash but you know if the captain starts
oh I don't know infringing on people's
human rights yes or starts setting a you
know bad example for the rest of
Americans and the rest of the world then
yeah I will speak up about stuff like
that and I will certainly stand up for
anyone's rights but you know it doesn't
matter who's president I would always
stand up for people's rights
so mmm you know I you know like I said
for me it's it's not about blaming
anyone it's not about you know being
angry or or you know trying I'm not
gonna go out and protest the Electoral
College I think that maybe it should
change and we should look into that and
I'd be happy to sign a petition to get
that looked at but but for all intents
and purposes like Trump is going to be
President and what else can we do
besides hope that he does a really
really good job this is an opportunity
for us to move forward and not close off
our bubbles but to expand them and I
think it's an opportunity for us to
better understand people we didn't
understand before yeah but it's a
wake-up offer it's a wake-up call for
people - yes absolutely - wake up Paul
wake up call for people to expand their
bubbles yeah I listen to the the the
media on this and Pete this was a
repudiation of much of the media as well
people disliked the discourse that's
going on in the media the the the
self-importance or the being self
congratulatory and hopefully if anything
this conversation between us well you
know I don't feel self-important about
this thing and in fact I want other
points of view in my life and that's why
you know I say and don't get me wrong I
love Missoula I love Montana I think
it's a beautiful beautiful place to be
but but I also realized there aren't the
same points of view here so if that if
you're in a place right now and you're
listening to this and you feel like well
I don't have those points of view around
me well the internet a gives you the
opportunity to to reach out across the
the ones and zeros to other people but
it also may mean moving somewhere else
where you can have
you can surround yourself with a bunch
of different viewpoints and hopefully
those viewpoints help you strengthen
your values your values won't change
necessarily but you'll uncover your
values and maybe your belief system will
change that they get you to those values
so let's take this as an opportunity
let's move forward
let's support people who are in fear who
feel like they're in danger and let's
let's create something meaningful
together realize that you are the person
who's going to make the most change in
your life despite any obstacles anyone
in government or elsewhere puts up for
you it just makes it a bit more
difficult and and so if you were playing
the game on novice or intermediate
before it may mean you're playing the
this this video game called life on a
more difficult or expert level and in a
and these times may be more difficult to
realize you have the support of people
who do care about you and we'll leave
you with that yeah I think I would just
add one more thing that if you go out
and throw yourself into a situation
where you're around if it's one person
or a bunch of people who have radically
different beliefs in you then you've got
to keep the anger on under check yes you
can do that by listening yeah exactly
like it don't go out it's it's not about
going out and convincing other people
that they're wrong it's about going out
and listening and and understanding why
other people feel the way they feel
because I'll tell you like if you go to
a trump supporter you're like okay I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna expand my bubble
I'm gonna go to like you know a pro
Trump rally and you might go there and
get really really ticked off and it'd be
really easy to start yelling at people
but doing that is never ever going to
move someone towards your side if
anything getting angry and reacting in a
visceral manner it is not going to have
someone look at you and say oh wow I'm
gonna go I'm not gonna support Trump
anymore it's just gonna make them hold
on to other Trump values or whatever
values you know even more so yeah just
be careful because that's kind of a kind
of double edged sword you want to go on
expand your ball
but you also don't want to go out and
stir arguments with people either on
that note I mean I think it's important
to realize that to expand the bubble one
of the best ways to expand the bubble is
to contribute yeah and so listening is
one way to expand the bubble but the
contribution is is another way to expand
the the bubble so maybe ask yourself how
can I use this as an opportunity to give
to other people because there are a lot
of people out there who who need help
and and whether they're a Trump
supporter or Hillary support or they
didn't vote at all that there are people
who who need your help and if you have
the capacity to help someone else one of
the best ways to understand them is to
give because you're understanding what
their needs are in order to give you
have to know what is needed and so
understanding someone's needs helps you
better understand that person and I
think that's really the reason that that
Ryan and I want to have this
conversation but also it's the reason it
goes back to why we started the the
minimalists six years ago is when Ryan
came to me after he had done his packing
party and simplified his life and and it
was about a year or so after I had
simplified my life maybe a year and a
half and it was hey maybe I think other
people can find value in this message
it's not a political message it's not
even an environmentalist message it is a
message is a recipe of things that have
worked that have helped improve our
lives so let's do that together no
matter where you are in the political
spectrum let's find ways to help improve
other people's lives with our creations
with our donations with our time with
our attention with our acceptance with
our love and with everything we've got
thanks for listening yeah thanks a lot
see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
thing that you gotta hang
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grin oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
team
you